covage vous avez entendu tout comme moi
le reportage de vincent est bon je peux
avoir donné l'impression qu'on fait un
bilan de la situation parce que ça fait
trois mois aujourd'hui que tout ça est
derrière nous non ça c'est passé l'idée
c'est plus de prendre une photographie
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe où on
en est rendu juste un rapport d'étape un
peu comme je disais alors vous ces trois
mois la la voulez vous les voyez comment
aujourd'hui à travers vos aux yeux de
médecins et qu'est ce qui vous en reste
et comment vous les analyser maintenant
il faut être très humble il faut
comprendre que ça a été un apprentissage
pour nous en terme de traiter des
patients
on ne traite plus les patients
aujourd'hui comme on les traités au
début il ya des choses qui sont restés
évidemment mais on a appris beaucoup
donc je pense que pour le traitement
pour l'aspect de traitement médical pure
et simple on est meilleur aujourd'hui
qu'on était il ya trois mois
ça c'est peut-être le point je dirais
positif le deuxième point c'est que sur
mon aspect hospitalier je pense qu'on a
fait un travail extraordinaire palais
juste le maintien loin de là mais
surtout les les infirmières les préposés
le personnel de soutien les ambulanciers
tous les gens qui ont travaillé très
fort les je vous dirai dans un set dans
ce combat là il ya eu un combat de
tranchées dans tous les jours dans les
hôpitaux dans les ch et celle des donc
je pense que les gens donnaient beaucoup
de même on n'a pas si vous savez c'est
comme c'est comme une game sur une
patinoire
on a il ya des gens qui ont compté
débuter un acteur ont reçu des buts mais
en bout de ligne là je pense que ceux
qui étaient sur la glace ont essayé de
donner tout ce qu'ils pouvaient le plot
point évidemment c'est le point de la
stratégie globale et j'espère qu'il y
aura de grandes leçons à tirer sur
l'impréparation le manque d'équipements
la la vitesse mais je dirais surtout la
lenteur avec laquelle beaucoup de
décisions ont été prises par exemple
lorsque les gens sont revenus l'arrêt
des voyages la fermeture des frontières
le qui devaient être testées on peut en
discuter pendant longtemps
donc c'est plutôt je vous dirais cette
réflexion-là qui devra être fait pour
être préparés éventuellement pour une
prochaine 20 ou pour
des choses futur semblables des
pandémies qui nous prendrait au bout du
nez un avenir parce que c'est ça aussi
qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'on n'était
pas prêts lorsqu'on entend dans le
tohoku de vincent un premier ministre le
goût dire écoutez on a des masses coup
on a des équipements de protection
peut-être pour cinq six jours c'est
jours encore ça donne froid dans le dos
1-1 on se dit là on est en train
carrément de réagir là de rendre à la
situation donc on n'avait pas de
réserves
on n'était pas prêt alors on était je
pense pas prêt c'est clair à l'échelle
du québec à l'échelle des hôpitaux
certains étaient beaucoup plus prêt que
l'autre mais il faut voir à l'échelle du
québec ce qui est un peu je vous dirais
dommages dans l'histoire c'est qu'on a
quand même eu le h1n1 en 2009 qui nous a
donné une leçon et qui nous a donné un
aspect de préparation on a eu
l'expérience du strass au canada pas au
québec mais on a quand même eu et je me
rappelle très bien du strass du travail
à faire au québec
donc on a eu je vous dirais des
entraînements on a eu des expériences
réelles qui nous ont mis en garde contre
ce genre de choses là il ya des choses
qu'on pouvait pas prévoir un beaucoup de
pays
tout le monde a été pris de court
jusqu'à un certain point il y en a qui
ont fait beaucoup mieux que d'autres
parce qu'ils ont une stratégie je vous
dirai qui a été beaucoup plus agressifs
sur certains aspects beaucoup mieux
coordonnés on a essayé d'utiliser au
québec
au niveau du ministère de la santé une
stratégie qu'on appelle top down mais
qui a été je pense à un échec sur book
sur beaucoup de points la réalité c'est
que le toac le top down l'aspect
stratégique est important mais l'aspect
tactique doit être laissée avec beaucoup
de latitude au niveau local donc il ya
un ensemble de facteurs qui ont fait qu
il va certainement falloir tirer des
leçons
tout le monde les médecins des
infirmières la stratégie de santé
publique
on a tous il faut être humble devant
tous aller et il faut tous et nos leçons
faut quand même aussi dire je pense que
c'est le point qui est important a
souligné qu' on était quand même
courageux d'avoir d'avoir pris une
décision à un moment donné dans
d'imposer un confinement a été massif au
québec parce que ça s'est jamais fait
dans l'histoire et ses terres
une inconnue alors il ça a été quand
même une décision importante et qui a
été probablement salutaire on n'a pas
fait d'études au québec mais quand on
voit l'impact du confinement dans
d'autres pays
et si on fait des extrapolations au
québec on le fera un moment donné on a
certainement sauvé des vies
à l'échelle globale et on a appris ben
c'est ça on a appris à se protéger aussi
parce que lorsque vous voyez monsieur
est rude à madame mais cannes et
monsieur legault un pardessus long très
très très collés on se dit dieu qu'on a
fait du chemin depuis ce temps là parce
que des scènes comme ça on ne peut plus
froid ça aujourd'hui on se distend aussi
bon tout l'utilisation du masque ici le
port du masque vous souhaitez qu'on
fasse la promotion du masque de manière
universelle
vous êtes toujours d'accord avec ça bien
sûr tout à fait ça fait très longtemps
que l'on a déjà institué le masque je
vous dirais universel dans mon hôpital
mais ça c'était pour les travailleurs de
la santé on a même été critiqué quand on
la sait initialement après sa main tout
le monde s'est mis à le faire de façon
je dirais en plus rapide et progressive
là on n'a pas de médicaments on a pas de
vaccin
il n'y a pas de parade magique contre ce
virus là donc il faut faire je dirais
feu de tout bois et le masque comme
qu'il avait répété hier même si certains
ont pensé que je disais que le lavage
des mains n'étaient pas bons au
contraire le lavage mais bon je mets le
lavage des mains ne remplace pas le
voulez vous lancer là-dessus dr weiss
derrière parce qu'on a eu évidemment on
est homme de commentaires lorsque vous
avez dit que le lavage des mains bon
était peut-être pas scientifiquement
prouvé en dame de québec qui s'appelle
céline poulain qui dit j'étais déçu
remercier d'entendre hier le dr weiss
dire qu'aucune étude scientifique n'a
démontré l'efficacité du lavage des
mains contre les coronavirus alors que
le virus qui cause des infections
respiratoires se propage par
gouttelettes et non pas par les mains il
a minimisé l'importance du lavage de
mains alors on en a eu plusieurs comme
ça alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez à ces gens qui
étaient quand même un peu surpris de vos
commentaires j'ai dit clairement hier
je ne veux surtout pas que les gens
pensent pas perverti nous ne faut plus
se laver les mains ça a été très clair
dans mes commentaires
donc le la
je démens c'est une mesure de base il
continue à exister dans tous les
principes de base de prévention des
infections
on en a discuté à de multiples reprises
je vous ai dit le lavage des mains c'est
la clé pour prévenir tout ce qui se
transmet par des contacts directs ou
indirects
c'est une mesure d'appoint pour la
qualif 19 mais ce n'est pas la mesure
qui va prévenir l'infection par des
gouttelettes au niveau de l'arbre
respiratoire quand vous êtes infecté la
majorité du temps avec la coved 19 c'est
parce que vous allez avoir un microbe
qui va rentrer au niveau de vos narines
au niveau de votre bouche à la limite au
niveau de vos yeux au niveau des
conjonctive et la façon de prévenir ça
la plus efficace c'est de porter un
masque de procédures ou même un masque
artisanale c'est une barrière physique
devant votre nez devant votre bouche qui
va l'empêcher
le lavage des mains est efficace c'est
une mesure d'appoint aux masses mais si
vous avez juste avec lavage des mains
six mois dans les hôpitaux dans mon
hôpital je vous laver les mains et je me
lave les mains souvent mais si je ne
portais pas de masse j'aurais
certainement été infectés par le nombre
de patients où j'ai vu clair écoutez
c'est beaucoup plus clair je vous
remercie infiniment docteur sachs
d'avoir été avec nous je vous souhaite
une bonne fête semaine et on se régale
on se revoit très bientôt au revoir